sometimes these movements have to be
driven by people who are true believers
because what happens is they they push
things all the way over and then it
comes back americans are not an extreme
people
we are not extreme americans are not
socialists
americans are not super right wing
americans want a better life for their
kids for the most part
and are too busy with with with their
everyday thing i got to take my kid to
baseball and i want to be able to afford
after school activities for my kids
that's what they really care about
i want a little extra cash
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report as always guys click that
subscribe button
and that little notification bell so you
have a small chance at least
of cnr videos and joining me today is a
comedian
and actor and co-host of the fighter in
the kid podcast
brian callan welcome to the reuben
report thank you sir
big fan big fan love it big fan here i
am
i finally made it you're in the internet
now i'm i'm
this is like the center of this
yes this right here everything that we
say here stays here no one will get in
any trouble
you're exactly fine as long as you uh as
long as you don't
express yourself freely and thoughtfully
and with reason
that seems like a good place to start
yeah comedy in an age of cancellation
how you feeling these days
i think that it feels as though this is
the last
bastion for satire honest expression
original self-expression
you know i've had comics call me and say
well i've got the show with a certain
network and i'm afraid that what i
said uh i expressed a point of view that
was more
complicated than some black or white no
pun intended yeah
you know oh you're going for it already
and uh should i
should i do this you you have comics now
wondering if they should edit themselves
in podcasts and my answer is if
that is what if if you are
um worried about that because you're
working for that network then you
shouldn't work for that network then
you're no longer a comic
then you're no longer in the business of
original self-expression
thoughts and art has always been there
to disturb
to shake things up let's take will and
grace
as an example i auditioned for that show
maybe five times i can't remember if it
was for jack
it was for eric it was for both and i
knew it was going to be a hit
but it was so groundbreaking it was so
astonishing it was the first time that
gay people were
kind of highlighted as this um as
people with senses of humor who wanted
the same thing that straight people want
i remember that being a radical
new uh idea
and it you know back then you know we
always talk about how you can get
canceled for certain words you say well
in the um well let's say all through all
of american history
up through probably the 90s
if you were found out to be gay in a in
the workplace
well if you didn't get fired you weren't
going to get promoted it was a
major liability and physically dangerous
so along comes will and grace
and a network took a risk so in that
sense
you know you can you can point to
examples where it's very important to
continue to speak your mind
and it's very important when the
pendulum swings
too far right or too far left or too far
in any direction as an artist you got to
push back
you got to kind of go you got to make
fun of it and that's the one
through all this insanity and there are
a lot of bad ideas out there and there
are a lot of sort of like
um these were very polarized there's no
room for nuance as you know
as i'm sure you've picked up on but um i
do think americans
have this really great safety valve this
switch which is humor
we tend to make fun of ourselves we tend
to make fun of
of canceled culture already we tend to
make fun of
of all these things there's
trump is always being made fun of and so
is the other side so i think
at least we are going to always
we'll always have that thing
even kids now my friend's son who is
16. my his my buddy said
look at that look at that butterfly i
wonder what he's gonna
land on next and his friend said dad
how are you assuming that's a he i mean
how do you know
and already kids are making fun of this
stuff yeah
so i think that's very healthy but
doesn't this seem a little unique in
that there's like a runaway train
aspect to it right now where it used to
be kind of like oh
one person randomly said one thing and
they get taken out where now it just
feels like the whole track got destroyed
the train is going off and everyone's
kind of going with it at the same time
if we were
if this was 1968 we'd be saying the same
thing
and we'd be even more panicked you know
um
i think right now we're dealing with a
confluence of events
yeah you're dealing with you know the
george floyd the terrible
murder of george floyd you're dealing
with covet 19 where nobody has jobs
nobody has anywhere to go to uh and
you're dealing with all these
uncertainties and you're dealing with
this incredibly polarizing figure
named donald trump so that all of that
stuff i think
is a perfect storm so it's when you're
in it it's hard to see
a way out of it and it's hard to see
sense i do think again
there are a lot of bad ideas out there
and i do think that um
but again if i'm a moderate person i
just
am i'm naturally moderate yeah medium
yeah
uh well when i was on your show we were
trying to figure out what we might
differ on politically we couldn't come
up with that
no i think you're a very reasonable i've
listened to you many times
and i and i've listened to your guests
and you're you know the truth is you are
a reasonable fair-minded person
don't tell that to the new york times
well yeah you know again
i think and then i i find myself saying
you know um sometimes these movements
have to be driven by people who are true
believers
because what happens is they they push
things all the way over and then it
comes back americans are not an extreme
people
we are not extreme americans are not
socialists
americans are not super right wing
americans
want a better life for their kids for
the most part and are too busy
with with with their everyday thing
i got to take my kid to baseball and i
want to be able to afford after school
activities for my kids that's what they
really care about
i want a little extra cash i mean if you
really come down to it
and i think that they the silent
majority
the most they ever really do is write
letters
tweet we tweet now come on you know
stuff like that but but but
you know come election time a lot of
times if
if if they feel like their bottom line
is being affected
i.e the way their children are being
raised educated
and uh and and whether or not they have
a little extra cash in their pocket
that'll get them to the polls yeah
otherwise
i got enough for this and i got enough
for that yeah i want to stick with the
comedy thing for a little bit because
you mentioned how if you're a comic and
you're working at a network that's
making you sense or making you question
yourself then you're working at the
wrong place
yes isn't it odd though that for all of
us that are now in the podcast youtube
whatever you want to call this thing
that now we're watching ourselves do it
to ourselves
we're our own bosses i'm not saying
you're doing it and i'm not doing it
but we know a lot of people now that are
getting in trouble because of what's
being said
on podcasts and we know that you know
media matters watches every word
yeah that somebody's going to say so
that if you know anybody says one thing
the wrong way
but you're gonna take them out even
though these guys own their stuff yeah
um but trouble when you say getting in
trouble the truth is
that um they're not the truth is that i
i look at getting in trouble as not
being able to earn a living
uh you know um corporations are
incredibly
in many ways spineless and we'll get
into that in a second
and what i mean by that but but um i
think that
you're still look i'm on stage all the
time i was in arizona i was in texas
um anywhere i go when i
when i say things that seem reasonable
when i criticize
the s sort of even whether it's
conservatives or liberals and i can i
criticize both people love it
people clap people laugh because uh
typically i think i always find that if
i'm feeling this way
so is most of the country because most
people are
they're just reasonable they're not
indoctrinated into an ideology
that is i think the danger in that is
that if you look at a lot of the media
and you look at a lot of um the
cognitive elite if you want to call in
that
they you know i think it was sam harris
who said i don't know anybody who smokes
camille paglia said i don't most of
these people don't know anybody who
listens to sport radio or works with
their hands or has been in the military
that's a big problem that's a huge part
of the country
and no they're not dumb no they're not
they're just as smart as anybody
in the cnn boardroom or in the
huffington post board room
or at fox news they're just as smart i
promise you they are i'm
not smarter in life yeah and and i've
been around
i've been around i'm old too old now
tutu and i've talked to
probably with my podcast my old podcast
i bet i've spoken to
i don't know i'll say 400 academics
maybe i'm wrong but a lot of them
and from really big universities because
they i would you know they'd they'd
write a book and i'd read it and i'd
interview them
they're they're specialized
they're specialized in one particular
field it doesn't mean they have a
comprehensive understanding of the world
and not not better
or not more more insightful than anybody
else
because they live behind very expensive
walls
they are in their own purified echo
chamber
they're terrified to step outside of
that echo chamber or
say anything that would great against uh
the
orthodoxy because they will get
destroyed
academia is a horrible place by their
own people oh they're not much not by
the other guy
oh my god destroyed by their own oh
they're not a charitable people at all
they're
awful and and it's it's it is what obama
called this circular firing line
um so i think it was another guy was
maybe vaclav schmel i can't remember
what
he said most of these people who are
driving this
debate who are coming up with these
terms like white privilege
like systematic racism and stuff like
that um
are at the bottom of a well and they're
looking up at their sliver of the sky
and all they can see is that sliver of
the sky
there isn't a comprehensive
understanding of the world when you live
in the real world and you have to make a
restaurant work when you have to manage
a restaurant
when you get down to the level of detail
nobody is talking about
your gender or your sex we got to get
the food to the customers man
and we got to stay in business which
means i don't have time for that i have
time for bottom line stuff
and then i got my kids and i got i got
to make my relationship work and i got
up
and i got this pain here so i'm nervous
about that
that's what it is to be a human being
yeah so a lot of this stuff when you say
getting in trouble
for what you said it's not real there's
a lot of chatter and a lot of white
noise yeah but you can ignore it your
job is to
just stay honest and and and be in the
business of original self-expression
and keep doing it because it's needed
and it's wanted bill burr
will say that billboard will be like he
says crazy things on stage and people
are like
oh i mean i've seen people go are you
allowed to do he not saying that and i
say to bill like oh you're so gutsy i
mean he goes no i'm not
eight people on twitter hate me
everybody else gets it and he's right
right they'll call him racist and then
it's like yeah but it's such a breath my
wife happens to be black
right not that that proves anything
that's not a get out of jail and it's
not anymore
being black isn't a get out of jail card
ask candace owens
ask larry elder ask thomas sowell yeah
these people are you know uh
uh shelby steele those people are not
they're persona non grata
on on university ask condoleezza rice
who wasn't allowed to speak i think at
wesleyan oh yeah concert pianist
smart woman but you're not on that side
so
those people are afraid they're afraid
of
true scholarship of nuance and of
of deep thinking and it requires that
what about the regular people though not
the comics that are supposed to be doing
this and the artists that are supposed
to be expressing themselves because
that's that's the big one i get now like
the amount of
mail i get every day from people that
are just like i have to be anonymous on
twitter
i can't post on facebook anymore all of
that stuff
because their job is not expression and
they're afraid they're going to lose
their job
if they they can yeah and that's what's
so disheartening is that
corporations if you work for a large
corporation they don't care
they're about their bottom line you
really think and
it's not that they're racist or anything
do you really think that
uh because adidas or nike or netflix
whoever stands
uh against racism do you stand against
racism guys i do like do you do yeah
that's awesome i don't know
if you could go back and stop slavery
would you wow
you're so noble and thanks for posting
that black square because that's what a
single mom
in the hood needs from you boy she must
be breathing a breath of fresh air and
she's trying to raise three kids
that must be fantastic and her other
kids just got picked up on a marijuana
bid
and is looking at getting stuck in the
system that he can't get out but thanks
for your black square
and thank you hollywood actors for
taking responsibility
i appreciate that because you guys are
making such a difference
it's embarrassing it's embarrassing and
thank you thank you for repeating the
phrase that was given to you
by someone you don't know like
systematic racism
and white privilege it sounds good it
makes you feel emotionally
cathartic i suppose what are you
actually doing
where were you when a hundred black
people were shot in chicago
over father's day weekend five of them
children who were killed
where were you why are you not in the
street there my friends
but you're not because you're too busy
because at the end of the day
you can't be unfortunately sometimes
things are bigger than you are
and so all you can do is is reach out
like a [ __ ]
and kind of say i let me tweet something
i'm against racism
i'm for peace and harmony you're for
peace and harmony
i'm for war and chaos dude i can't
believe that
but your bumper sticker and that thing
you put up in your store really has
changed my mind
so i i just see a bunch of um it's like
watching a bunch of people on on
stationary bicycles trying to get
somewhere and i
it's it's embarrassing there's a guy
that's about five houses over i will
walk out with you after this and show
you who's got the bernie bumper sticker
and you know co-exist and the whole
thing and he has literally the biggest
fence in the neighborhood
the biggest not only does he have a
fence in front of his house his door has
a fence in front of it i've never even
seen this before i'm sure they have more
of them in beverly hills
but like a you know his front door extra
fence right there and it's like oh well
you got all the bumper stickers right
right suddenly you like fences look i've
never been a fan of donald trump i don't
like his personality i don't think he's
an effective leader i have a lot of
criticisms i did not vote for him
um i'm not a fan never have been did you
vote for hillary i i did vote for
hillary and i don't like hillary
i i i didn't know what to do i couldn't
vote for that guy yeah i just
he he just uh and and especially in the
beginning when
he was like you know if if i have i want
to ban on muslims
i want to build a wall it just all
sounded un-american
but my biggest criticism of trump is
that he's he's a trumpist
yeah i mean you know if i were debating
trump i'd be like you care about trump
you don't care about the country so i i
have my my criticisms
but what's interesting about the sort of
and i was a critic of the i don't like
the idea of building a wall there's got
to be a smarter way to do this i mean
you know
i just it just ugh it just sounded
terrible so
but but what's interesting about the
most vocal
the people that are really against the
wall
and things is the people that are doing
that live behind very expensive walls
try getting in
try getting over the wall that is
harvard the wall that is
yale the wall that is princeton the wall
that is wesleyan the wall that is
uh williams college house well forget
that
forget that isn't she responsible for
the tenderloin and uh isn't that her
district in in uh or is that maxine
waters the late mexican i'm not sure oh
vaccine is here yeah yeah
yeah so i mean of course so you people
live behind
very expensive walls i can't afford
those walls yeah and i don't have the
grades
so but why is it people can't connect
those two things well here's another
thing
that i thought of and i thought kansas
owens was had said in
because what i've been doing lately is
i'm on youtube and i watch debates
between black conservatives and black
liberals
and i get a lot from both sides yeah i
love it i'm not
i'm not you know it's it's very
interesting i i'm the guy who's been my
dad had me reading thomas so a long time
ago you know this stuff
but but what's what's uh interesting is
that
she said look if if black lives really
matter and you
you are worried about black the black
sort of uh
vote and the black you know political
influence which is what it comes down to
especially in local politics
you better get serious about
criminalizing the border
because if you have unchecked
immigration from south of the border
the latino vote god bless them is going
to render your vote as an
african-american
obsolete you can say whatever you want
but when it comes down to getting votes
politicians are going to be able to skip
over your districts
it's not going to matter in five years
and i i i kind of
i went ooh wow oh that's a that's a
contradict that's a real that that puts
the left
in a real predicament here it really
does
because now you've got to get very
serious about uh immigration
maybe even draconian hard terrible
terrible problem when you have children
and you have desperate people trying to
come over your border
i don't know the answer i don't know how
to solve that but what a dilemma
and what a corner they have painted
themselves in yeah and there's studies
by the way that show that
latino immigrants who've come here
legally are now
actually much harsher on illegal
immigration than your average white
liberal
because they came in the right way and
serving people
yeah and they've become the new
conservatives yeah they they make up a
lot of the school boards in this country
and they're catholic and they're
conservative and you know they're very
they're they're tight-knit families and
stuff like that yeah i'm starting to
think that maybe judging people by the
color of their skin and their ethnicity
maybe that can't hold
long term dave you mean treat people
like individuals you mean what the
principles this country was founded on
yeah look we've always been we've always
been a country that is
we are a contradiction we've been doing
this racial dance
and um my jamie masada who's the owner
of the laugh factory told me an amazing
story about
when when richard pryor showed up this
is in the 70s
paul mooney was there paul had a big
afro
and paul mooney uh richard pryor came in
with this crazy mercedes and paul mooney
goes what are you doing bro that's a
white man's car you crazy
and richard breyer said what are you
talking about and he said
get in the car so paul mooney gets in
the car he says i'm driving
so paul had this afro it's richard pryor
it's two other comics i think one was
black as well
maybe and then jamie masada in the back
and they take a drive
and they got stopped four times for
swerving
and finally a black cop in beverly hills
said you're richard pryor he's the
greatest thing in the world and they let
him go
but they went to brentwood they went to
beverly hills
and so it what there is no doubt that
historically there is no doubt if you're
african-american you have a different
relationship with the police
than you do if you're white there's no
doubt about that i would never argue
that in a million years
the question is the question is what do
we do about it
what do we do about it dismantle the
police force
so these are the these are the bad ideas
that i think are these reactionary ideas
so the billion they're cutting from new
york city policing
that de blasio wants to get rid of as as
crime is now i think murders directions
that'll be his political liability and
and de blasio
is not a man who lives in reality in my
opinion
and i think he's a guy who uh you know
he's talking about how
i don't think he's ever had a real this
it i don't think he's ever had a real
job
and and um he'll tell you if he was here
he'd say i run
uh a company that's got 50 000 employees
and i know
i know bill i know that's good good on
you except for you don't have to turn a
profit right
and it doesn't mean you run it well and
it doesn't mean you run it well and
he's got a very strong it seems to me
from what i've heard a socialist
ideology he speaks like a lot of
politicians did
in sweden in the 70s and uh let's see
what happens
yeah let's see what happens i'm not
impressed so far i
i do think that police unions are very
powerful i do think they got they get
a lot of money to the to the tune of
sometimes they get too much money in
terms of these tax base
in those towns like stockton can't
afford
to support the firemen safety union
the police union michael lewis wrote a
good book highlighting this in
a book called boomerang i recommend it
to people and he highlights california
so sometimes when you're talking about
defunding the police
you're talking about taking money away
from those very powerful unions and
putting it into other programs
i understand that again again
you know when i dismiss it as a liberal
argument i'm not being fair there are
very smart people on the left
who are looking at data as well and they
have something to offer
so i don't want to you know right well
look
you know where i stand on this and it's
like if you told me you were cutting
budgets if you told me you were cutting
basically every city
federal state the whole thing budgets by
20 across the board
i think i think we'd be just fine i
don't think when you're looking at 150
increases in murder that you that what
you should be doing optically if
if not even granularly or correctly you
should be
doing it because it just doesn't look
right but uh you mentioned something to
me right before we started
i had giuliani on a couple weeks ago and
when you say that de blasio's you know
not qualified or it's like what has he
done to prove that he can run this city
well giuliani the guy's got a pedigree
he was an attorney general he was
hunting down the mafia well his father
got shook down by the mafia right so he
talks about that so his whole life in
many ways led
to being the mayor the guy in charge of
the most important city
during the most terrific terrorist
attack the whole thing uh you were
telling me a little bit about what it
was like to be
in new york city you got you got a
couple of years on me so there were some
things that you remember
i remember new york my mother and father
my mother was born and raised brooklyn
uh you know and then she went to
westchester county but my my my family
the italian science dad born in brooklyn
my mom grew up in westeros all right
well good so the italian side
the sicilian side are all brooklyn
staten island and then uh some in
westchester
so uh i would always i grew up overseas
my whole life but when i finally went to
college in washington dc
i would come up to new york to see my
family and i had my friends in new york
and so
i remember what new york was like in 87
88 89 90. when you went down to tompkins
square park
when they when they shut it down and
redid it they found
diseases in the soil like tetanus like
bubonic plague
i mean you the when my grandfather found
out i was hanging out in
on avenue a i was dating uh patty
jenkins who is the great director of
wonder woman
and she lived on avenue a and 11th
street and
when i would go down there man i was
always so nervous because it was mad max
it was
chaos it was crazy and my grandfather
couldn't believe
i was hanging out down there and there
was an expression back then
if you hung out on avenue a you're
adventurous b you're a bold see you were
crazy and d
you were dead and i'm telling you man my
when i used to go see my buddy john
joseph
who is the lead singer of the crowmags
this is in 1989
this was probably 91 91. people don't
believe this but it was 91.
it was right where cbgb's was i could
not he would have to meet me
on houston street because we would go
into
like where ludlow street try buying an
apartment there now
see how much it costs you forget it i
mean you can't look at a place for under
three thousand
dollars a square foot well it's a little
less now because the city ain't doing
okay
maybe a little less maybe a little less
yeah i was i could not
he had to walk me because i'd get jumped
by the local kids
the gangs that were hanging out there
and i i would walk with him but if i
wasn't walking with him
i was in trouble and he he was adamant
about that he goes you can't you got i
got to meet you i'm just afraid that you
know somebody will mess with
you so to see that radical shift under
giuliani it was kind of amazing
look i don't know what it's like to run
be the mayor of
a city i don't know bill de blasio i
don't know what the challenges he faces
i do have a sense of what his ideology
is and i don't think it's the best thing
in the world for
i we are very different do you consider
yourself that political
it's interesting because you're sort of
political but also it strikes me as more
just like
look uh i care about life or something i
think albert camus
said in the 20th century no one can
afford to not be politically and
philosophically committed
and the 20th century saw what happens
when you're on the wrong
side of the coin when when
bad ideas win
when bad ideas like collectivism and
fascism
uh win the day people die
people die and i can take you to 80
million graves
to prove that point see the the 40-year
european civil war called world war one
and world war
ii uh and and and the red
and the the famines in china and the
famines and force collectivization
in stalin's russia etc etc
so my favorite expression is you may not
be interested in politics but it's
interested in you and it will come for
you
so yes i'm political and yes i'm
philosophical and it's very difficult to
earn
your opinion it's difficult it takes a
lot of time it takes a lot of reading
and it requires you to change your mind
and stay humble so
i i guess i am political but i don't
know i try to be
i try to be middle of the road well i i
no a better way to say it is i try to be
responsive
to the evidence i try to really listen
to people i disagree with
i do and i and i get a lot out of it i
try to listen to people who are
for example um uh the the uh
liberal i've read a lot of tanahasi
codes and tahati is
you know would be considered on the sort
of left side of the spectrum in
in black intelligencia he's a beautiful
writer man
he writes it's almost like these psalms
he writes they're so moving god
i mean that guy's an incredible writer
it's okay to be really moved by
something and have it emotionally move
you
and to believe it and to have it affect
your dna
and still fundamentally rationally maybe
disagree
with the big picture and to be more on
the side of someone like uh i think it's
john
worthener or or larry elder or or
shelby steele or thomas sowell um
there is room for both there's room for
both do you think some of that's just
emotional makeup that some of the guys
that lean right they tend to just focus
more
on provable facts versus perhaps the
pros that you're talking about or
something like that you know like
it depends on where your brain's at yeah
coleman coleman coleman hughes
um who's sort of a disciple a young
disciple i mean colin uses figuring his
way through the world as his candice
owns but
both of them are are very energetic very
intelligent uh uh very articulate
human beings who happen to be they've
just read
they're parroting with all due respect
they're inheriting the the the the great
thinker the towering intellects like
thomas soul and stuff and not to take
anything away from them i have a lot of
guys learn from people they have a lot
of guts and they're taking on the fight
um but colin hughes said something
really really interesting about
uh he and werthner were talking and said
well you know we sound very
white they said and we we sound very
rational
and we sound we're both kind of atheists
and what martha
martin luther king had going for him he
was not terrestrial
he was up there and he was speaking
i mean they they the if
killer mike is one of my favorite
americans i might vote for killer mike
i love that guy that guy's read it all
right that guy's so brilliant i mean
he's a guy who i really really
jive with because he seems like he's on
both sides
we need someone as articulate
and as of that community see
when i hear someone speak something like
my killer mike speak
i and most people go that guy comes from
a part of the world where things like
bills rent are all you can think about
where where where where he knows a lot
of kids who've been either
shot put in jail rightly or wrongly or
living in that
in that they're caught up in the system
and they pay for it with their blood
they pay for it with their
with with losing years on their life
with you know just
their grandmother's the only one who
owns a house because she got it and then
and then somebody's trying to take it
from them because
they live these terrible things until
the
the sort of black intelligence yeah they
were this is this is what they were
saying until they have someone
who is that theatrical who can really
speak
with that musicality and that dramatic
uh effect uh they will always be the
guys who are kind of
you guys are just you guys are kind of
over there and you're too rational
yeah human beings change their
we keep forgetting that people on the
right and the left
you know we keep forgetting that it's
about changing minds
it's about persuasion i i get that you
have your point of view and i get that
you have your graphs
and i get that you can point to things
like that but you know if you speak like
uh tucker carlson or if you speak like
coleman hughes or whatever it is
or if you speak like whatever they are
very
thoughtful rational people who make very
good arguments a lot of times that's not
how your mind is changed
your mind has changed when someone can
hit you here and hit you here and that's
what someone like tallahassee codes has
you you you that's where art
and comedy and satire
come into play you change people's minds
by getting them to laugh
getting them to relax getting them to
feel
valued getting them to understand that
the way they feel
matters it's it's it's not
you know the reason a lot of black
people are really upset and taking to
the streets is not made up
that that that has to be acknowledged
and it has to be seen
and we have to see that first and then
you find a way
to get nuance in there because they are
open to nuance
not yet sometimes not yet human beings
at first when we're first when you hit
me when i get hit in the mouth
you got to give me a second because i
want to hit you back it's my instinct
if you if i'm holding on to something
that i care about a lot you pull it out
of my hand
i'm going to reach for it even an infant
does that you got to give us time to
reach
for it let me grab it back let me hold
on to it
give me a day give me a year and then
we'll come back
and we'll we'll have the debate and
we'll be able to get all those little
things in
there and i think that's what why i take
heart in this country
because at the end of the day we always
seem to come back here and we
figure it out and we make fun of how
crazy we were when we were having our
tantrum
on the right and the left and then we
somehow figure out when we get down to
the level of detail
it it kind of makes it sense in its way
here i i'm
i'm an optimist i was gonna say you're
you're an optimist i am
yeah i am i think that's what happens i
think that's who you and i are
and i think that's who uh a lot of
people are well it's funny because
people always say to me
are you an optimist or a pessimist and i
always say well i i'm a world weary
optimist i don't think i could do this
if i wasn't an optimist you know i mean
like if i didn't fundamentally believe
oh we actually can change people or any
of this actually matters
what the hell would we be doing all day
why would we be talking to all these
people reading these books and the rest
of it it would be
it would just be an exercise in futility
but you're jewish dave and so sam harris
yeah
and so so our um uh doesn't usually end
well for the jews no no but but the the
tradition
in the jewish and ben shapiro the
tradition in the jewish
whether you know it or not yeah the
history of the jews
yeah moses debated moses argued with god
moses god called them the stiff neck
people for debate
debate a rabbi would always there are
plenty of stories in the old testament
and and and you know of rabbis and
you when even if god were to come down
and perform a miracle yeah the rabbis
would say well how can we be sure of
that
yeah so jews at a table for opinions the
jews have always been
in a very precarious position they've
always been this tiny minority
who are the greatest innovators of all
time because they've always been on the
outside
looking in and saying something's not
right here sorry to rock the boat but
it's not fair
you know think about it think about
sigmund freud
who i mean sigmund freud was a jew who
said
uh there's something called the
subconscious what oh and by the way you
secretly want to have sex with your mom
what do you know how heretical do you
know how outrageous that was
albert einstein said hey guys i know
that uh isaac newton
said that you know there's there's
something called time and it's the alpha
and the omega uh times relative
yeah what time bends and uh so
everything you've ever heard
including the bible is wrong they called
him they called it jewish science
they called it dadaism yeah i mean so so
um
you are you are standing well in your
tradition you should be
speaking truth to power you should be
pushing back
you should be debating um that is one of
the greatest
uh gifts i i i would i get hit up
sometimes by nazis
they follow my email they find my email
and i love to have these arguments
right i love to sit there and go i'm
glad that you've been you're parroting
what some [ __ ] has put in your head
yeah and now let me let me debate you
so you're spending time during the day
debating nazis i i like to try to change
minds
and that's what we have to do because
they're usually young angry men who have
nowhere to place their energy
and if you can if you can start to talk
to them
it's how i my mind was changed that way
dave
my mind was changed that way i was a
young man do you remember a moment
very well i was a i was a young man in
um
in theater school and i had never really
met anybody who was gay
and my wonderful the man who changed my
life
a couple of men have changed my life um
but he was
this wonderful teacher at the
neighborhood playhouse named richard
pinter and he had this giant mustache
and he was a
gay man and openly gay and i'd never met
i was 22. i never really actually
and he was he said he started talking to
me and he said uh oh i that embarrassed
you and i said
i said oh what and he said
oh you have one idea of what it is to be
a man don't you yeah
you have a very strong idea of
masculinity but you know being emotional
is also masculine
it was the beginning of my journey of
you know so so so i i was
i was suddenly exposed to um the theater
world in new york and i was around
gay people and and then um but but if
you had told me that that
two gay people especially two gay men
could raise a child
i remember arguing with a girl and
saying that's not
no we can't have that it's not safe for
the kid i don't
remember what i was saying but i was 21
or 22 or 20
and she was raised by two gay parents
and um she changed my mind she changed
my mind
well she didn't she got me started and
then i
grew up and i started to take a look at
the world and i started to read and i
started to think
and i matured and i lo and behold
now i'm pro-gay marriage and i'm
and i'm pro what i know and guess what
else i am i'm pro-legalization of drugs
and i'm you know i'm all those things
i'm i'm pretty libertarian in a lot of
ways
but that doesn't mean i don't believe in
some government i'm not i'm you know i
think we do need some
yeah well that's where when when i was
on your show we started talking about
that stuff and trying to figure out all
right so where are our
misaligned things are you for legalizing
all drugs you would you're you're down
to this
meth and crack and i don't know i don't
know i find myself saying i don't know a
lot
i i i because you mentioned michael
malus right before we started he's down
to legalize absolutely everything and
i've debated this with him
you know weed sure all the psychedelic
stuff absolutely yeah and i wouldn't
want to be putting people in jail
because of
you know doing small amounts of coke or
something like that
but to me you can't i know that if if
everything was legal
that if my next door neighbor was was
cooking meth
it is not good for the community it's
not good for you he wouldn't have to
customize meth
if it was legal right he'd be able to
get it if it yeah but if more and more
people were doing these things and i
know it's not a perfect argument because
people aren't necessarily doing it
not doing it because it's illegal yeah
well well the way i look at it is this
there are there must be personalities
who are going to do that stuff anyway
right
i mean think about it for sure think
about it if i was doing a lot of blow i
don't have time
yeah i went to a party in seattle one
time after my show and yeah everybody
was doing blow
and i and i they were offering me blood
you know as a comic i've had that
i got to wake up i gotta catch a flight
or i got a life i can't
well you just don't and also i don't
want my heart to stop yeah but there are
a lot of things where you go
who's how do you guys you know so so or
but i mean uh
i also don't have time to do math it
doesn't work out very well right right
so some of these students yes
i know some of us don't have time nobody
ever had a lot of problems did meth and
then it got better
never said no one ever right yeah so
sometimes i think that
i i don't know if anybody you know
there's a lot of scotch available
anytime i want i got a bunch of it in my
house
i don't have time to get to drink scotch
i don't feel well the next day it
doesn't
doesn't go with me but some people can't
stop drinking scotch so i really wonder
if all of this stuff was zoned and it
was
available the way any kind of a drug
could be under supervision or whatever
it is
would you do it well if you get caught
in your car on meth
if you get caught in your car and you're
wired you're gonna go to jail or if you
get
tested at your workplace you're going to
be in trouble so
i i think responsible people still
wouldn't have the luxury
or wouldn't want to do it so that's my
argument there i i i
i i do think you maybe would have more
accidental ingestion of things and i
don't
but um how is the war on drugs going so
far just curious
no quite horrible yeah just wondering
look how about marijuana
let's talk to the mexican illegal yeah
talk to the mexicans talk to the mexican
population
the people that have to live with this
stuff the the uh
how many bodies have they had to uh bag
uh
innocent innocent civilians and stuff so
i'm not impressed
and there's a lot of money in this stuff
but
uh i'm not impressed collective madness
exists
and uh i am not impressed with for
example i've just read two books
on the afghanistan wars stephen cole
wrote ghost wars
and he wrote directorate s and he did an
exhaustive
study he's a washington post journalist
an exhaustive study
on the cia wars in afghanistan and how
in our relationship with
pakistani special services the isi
and boy oh boy boy oh boy uh
did we make we've been there for 17
years and the longest war in american
history yeah
and every year the generals in the
pentagon would say
this is the decisive year baby we're
going to turn the corner
and they tried everything these are not
dumb people they tried it all any
argument you can come up with
we gotta have local people we gotta win
hearts and minds they know all that they
did it all they did everything they
could as well as they could
but boy did they get good at killing
taliban and boy you better be careful
when you have a president like george w
bush or anybody else who looks at these
people and says
who who labels an entire group of people
like they're the good guys and they're
the bad guys be careful of binary
thought patterns good guys bad guys
taliban baathists and everybody else
all that crap you better be careful
doesn't work out historically
so um i don't know where i was going
well does either book go into why we're
there i feel like nobody even knows why
we're there
because i know there was an argument is
that a taliban
17 years ago but i'll tell you why we
were there yeah we went in there to get
rid of al qaeda yeah
problem is then when al-qaeda after tora
bora after all of them
found themselves in the the waziristan
the hinterlands and in pakistan
we had all these we had this entire
military apparatus
we had these highly trained commandos
who had nothing to do
and even though the taliban were
reaching out
under mullah omar who said we want to
share in a ruling we want to share
in in in ruling the new afghanistan
would just cut us in
come to the negotiating table when you
have someone like george w and people
say no the taliban are all barbaric
which maybe they were but we can't
negotiate with them the way they did
with
anybody who was baptist in iraq uh and
and then you
you add to the fact that you have to
then we also by the
way have to fight another war we have to
invade iraq in 2003. i know we haven't
done anything yet in
afghanistan we have to let's do a
two-front war
um what happens is these you have this
military apparatus
and who do they who do they turn to well
arcade is not there anymore but the
taliban is there
and they're there and they harbored al
qaeda
so they must be terrorists too and so
when you cut them completely out when
you take away
any option for them to participate
in the ruling of the new afghanistan
they have to fight
and so you you call them taliban and
i've talked to a lot of soldiers
tip of the spirit guys about this and
i've talked to
i've read enough on on and people that
were really involved in this stuff
uh you call him taliban that's a kid
who's 14 15 16 17 18
who doesn't have anywhere to turn and
that local group
called the taliban are going to give
them four squares and a cot
and a sense of pearl three squares in a
cot and a sense of purpose
yeah well that's what happens so now
you're fighting taliban
you're fighting everybody it's fighting
how we we stay in these places and i
think if you asked
i think it would be something like 75
percent of americans if you said let's
just leave today let's just
let's just get out we don't know why
we're there nobody knows why that's why
i started the question like that like
nobody really knows
that's not how we know how it was sold
but right that's not how government
works on intent
yeah every every politician and every
government including the pentagon so i
love these guys who are like
i favor small government although we
can't cut the military's budget yeah you
got to have that
okay how is that going again i would cut
it it's so
taboo to talk about the military and
stuff like that bloated bureaucracy
so is the cia so is dia so is
so is uh the national security agency so
is all of it
they're huge bloated bureaucracies and
anybody who's in it will tell you that
no they're not sacred no it's not hands
off yes you should criticize them yes
you should hold them into account
because i'm not impressed and you and
and and it you know whose fault it is
you can't find anybody's fault they're
all a lot of people are highly competent
very intelligent people the problem with
any government
agency including the military and the
intelligence apparatus
is it continues to grow as no politician
wants to be seen
being soft on military soft on
intelligence
soft on terrorism so you gotta package
these things
you gotta pass things like the patriot
act you're against the patriot act
you must not be a patriot so you so
packaging words are very important
black lives matter are you going to say
they don't
are you against that it's very very
shrewd of any movement when you the
first thing you do with a movement is
you
you word it properly you got to spend a
lot of time in that boardroom
coming up with a really cool irrefutable
marketable name or phrase
and the military does it and
administrations
do it all the time you're not a
progressive you're not for progress
what are you for there you go buddy
there you go and that's what you better
be careful of
and i don't think most americans are
hoodwinked i think most americans know
that
thank god i'm i have a lot of faith in
the common man
all right we talked about new york city
yeah we talked about afghanistan
seems like the segway to where we're at
right now in california
what do you make about what's going on
with this state we we both we talked
about it about a month ago on your show
yeah i was strongly considering leaving
like i was looking at real estate i had
a whole bunch of people
begging me to come to dallas i would
have had a pretty sweet operation over
there yeah
my feeling right now is i want to stay
and fight here i love i love socal
i love you know i love the weather of
course and all that but like i've built
a good life here we've got
friends i like it here it's a freaking
mess absolute mess i think you're in a
bit of a similar
situation i am and i i didn't think
about staying and fighting until i spoke
to you
and i haven't stopped thinking about
that and i think you're right
um i i was just in austin looking at
property
and boy does that oh i know we probably
i told you we're probably looking at the
same houses i'm on truly like man what i
can get in austin
the amount of money i can save it's
cheaper to live it's that you know i
don't pay that 13
tax or whatever it is or 18 um so yeah i
could save a lot of money
and um what's happening in california it
seems is businesses are leaving for just
that reason
because it's very expensive to do
business here what california has going
for it is a very diversified economy
and amazing weather um and it's just a
huge important state for a lot of
reasons but california was the state
that worked
and we have a democratic super majority
and uh if you look at local politics
it's
it's just anytime you have a super
majority of any
group i don't care if it's republican or
democrat i don't think that's good for
democracy
your vote if you are someone who leans
even a little bit right doesn't count
save it stay home we don't care and you
aren't getting elected to local office
you're not getting elected to to
government office you're not unless you
are
pro-big union across the board good luck
good luck otherwise and i'm a member of
a union i'm in sag
so i i understand the value of unions
but
it's expensive to do business and unless
you can
push back a little bit or come up with a
compromise i don't
i don't i'm not bullish on california
and that ain't me i've talked to some
very smart people
who are economic animals and
all of them agree and all of them are
looking to get out because
it's too expensive why why i live in
on skid row basically i'm in venice i've
been in venice for 25 years i love it
but i don't recognize my town anymore as
much
and you know it's gotten really bad over
there right it's not just gotten very
bad it's become profitable
because developers now can get these
government contracts i mean
i can build you i can build you a bunch
of apartments for 200 million dollars on
prime real estate
on a parking lot in on the beach if
you'd like i'd be happy to do that and
we can just have we can create a
homeless uh
uh apartments people for for people who
are homeless
and uh don't worry about doing drugs or
anything else we're not gonna put any of
those restrictions on
you can come and go as you like you know
so so
there is something that seems this is
not me but a scholar i had a long
conversation with called the
the homeless industrial complex once
there's money
in bidding and getting
uh homeless shelters for big developers
you better be careful so these people
need to be put in treatment
the majority of the people on the street
is not a housing problem
it's not a housing problem it's not a
housing problem it is a
mental health and addiction problem and
until we get serious about that
uh we're we're going to be in big
trouble is it weird to you watching it
spread in different areas so venice
always had a certain amount of that now
it's definitely more but like hollywood
which also always had a certain amount
it's like kind of taking over hollywood
if you just go to straight up
especially now where there aren't as
many other people on the streets now it
just seems like all there
are kind of like transient people and
homeless and tents
and well you and as that inches closer
to west hollywood now it'll lynch closer
to beverly hills and that that then is
oh my gosh
that meant it gets pushed yeah well you
know they have their own police force
but yeah prop 47 and you can't it's not
criminalized they're all kind
these i voted for 47 because the way it
was phrased
and it had it had the again on the
ballot
as i'm voting i went well this makes
sense i don't want kids to be in a
revolving door of crime
and and police chiefs back it and did
you read the whole thing
i didn't that's it i didn't have time
i i'm but that's how they get you in
this state
i think more than any other during the
last election there was this one thing
on the ballot
about um you know do you want it it was
something like this do you want to put
500 million dollar
uh into education for you know blah blah
blah
and then there's essay just a giant
crazy essay on the whole thing and i
skipped all the way to the bottom
and on the bottom it says this can only
be repealed or reversed
by popular vote but nobody ever
says okay now we'll take the money from
the kids
but that's government 101. that's right
you sell it exactly the packaging thing
you're talking about
away nobody reads the fine print and
then you throw it back on the people to
be like oh you'll have to take care of
this
deal with this there's always blow back
there's always a ripple effect
no matter what the intentions are you
know we've spent something like three
trillion dollars on
programs for the poor how's that going
how's it going
you know it it it's very difficult i i
think at the end of the day
it's not about right or left you've got
to ask yourself do you really think that
a bloated bureaucracy called the federal
government
is the first line of defense is that the
best way to solve these problems
is it i don't i don't i don't think so
is government gonna keep
families intact is it government
official or a bureaucrat
who studies family law or whatever going
to keep your family intact
are they gonna are they gonna get you to
take care of your kids
are they going to get you the skill set
you need in the 21st century the
ever-changing 21st century
it's a question yeah maybe the answer is
yes in some cases but i don't know if
that's
always the question the answer and
you've got to ask those questions
the problem we run into is we go well
i'm a republican i'm a democrat i'm left
i'm right there there's
no no hold on hold on let's let's go
into what percentage of your money do
you want to give the government every
year every day i i pay something like 52
in taxes so half my day half my year
is working for someone else half my day
half my year
is working for someone else so how much
more do you want from me
uh what do you want we can negotiate
this especially in this biz where you
also gave a lot to your agent and your
lawyer
i know it's like no no no it's not
crying me a river it's just i just know
what they're doing
i got to make two that's always been the
case for me yeah it's fine yeah so
that's you you i'm giving you half my
money now is it being spent wisely
i bet you i could find cases where it's
not yeah and that's just the way it is
when you're a giant
state and federal bureaucracy it just is
so
is there a better way to do this is
there you know i i have my charities
that i
that i do i have my own personal things
so um i think there is
and i think that we have to be creative
and i think that
creativity and beating bad ideas with
better ideas
comes from individuals i don't think it
comes from group think
i think groupthink is dangerous and i
think groupthink is oppressive and i
think groupthink
is becomes orthodoxy
and tyrannical and if you disagree with
me
try to get somebody on the board of any
corporation
to speak honestly and with nuance
about any of these topics they'll all
say
i'm not touching that one there's
something wrong with that there's
something wrong with the fact that
people
on boards who are reasonable thoughtful
go i
there's something wrong with when when
the entire board of nike which is all
white pretty much
um has to take these very sort of like
when
and another thing we're we're not racist
at all i mean you know
and they do a lot for the communities of
color where do they make their shoes by
the way
is there any problems with that maybe
maybe not again
very good company and a very you know
profitable company and they do employ a
lot of
but uh so goes the dance
yeah so goes the dance here this is the
dance we've been doing for a long time
and i'm an optimist because this country
is a great is the great experiment
that's what we called it right it is a
great experiment it's like that famous
story whether it's true or not when
abraham lincoln came out so what did you
do in there and we created a republic
madam if you can keep it
it's a great it's a great way to say it
um
so i i i don't know i don't know man i i
think we have to keep
to the fact that this country is also
built on a contract which is keep your
promises don't take what doesn't belong
to you
and if you violate this those first two
principles then
you have to have courts that can make it
right and okay
and all of that requires an objective
mindset
and an objective set of laws
and objective institutions
you know calen i should end it right
there because that was a beautiful well
there was no music to it i liked it we
could
use it a little well if you could we
could put something in post and i wanted
a fan but my hair i it's not long enough
i just like that
it's all amazing that was a beautiful
perfect ending thank you but
you've led me to the obvious question
good then to really end this thing which
is
all right you're going to stay in
california you're making a lot of sense
people like you uh-huh governor mean
would you ever get into politics because
this i he this is
happens all the time i get people in
here who are great
thoughtful interesting open decent all
that stuff
yeah and then it's like well all right
do you want to get in and
it's what people ask me all the time and
i'm like no freaking way
i i like stand up too much you know i i
i will never stop basically yeah he is
yeah i i i would never want to do
politics because i think
uh that if i were in gavin newsom's
place or eric garcetti's place and i've
been critical of them because i don't
know what it is to be
them and i don't know what it is to have
their job but i think that i would
probably
find myself in a very similar position
as those guys
and i'd probably go oh i was a little
harsh on that
because i had a conversation with arnold
schwarzenegger about that i was with
john leguizamo and i and i talked to him
about what it was like to be governor
and i got some pretty amazing insight
and one of the things you'll always hear
someone in power say whether they're
governor or president
they always say the same thing which is
i didn't have nearly as much power as
people think i did
i didn't have any power a lot of times
i'll say yeah i couldn't do anything
the founding fathers wanted a country
like that they wanted government to move
slowly they didn't want
power to rest in in one person's hands
thank god
so uh look at the amount of pushback
trump gets thank god yeah
so um i i i love
doing what i do i love being a comic
that's my that's
that's all i care about sometimes that's
when i feel the most alive
i think if i had to be a politician and
go through all of that
and and and and the frustration of
having to
compromise and to see how things really
work you know it's like that expression
you don't want to see how sausages are
made or
or laws are made yeah and you'd have to
you'd have to you'd have to lie
because all right it is we gotta just so
the point is i'm running for common
who knows if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about comedy instead of the non-stop
yelling you get everywhere else check
out our comedy playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell